الصراع الاثري الارمنيه عود الى الواجهه
بعد اعلان اذربيجان شمم وصفتها بعمليات
لمكافحه الارهاب تستهدف القوات الارمنيه
في اقليم كاراباخ المتنازع عليها ارمينيا
نفد وجود قوات نظاميه تابعه لها هناك
وطالبت المجتمع الدولي بالتحرك لوقف
مواصفاته بعدوان اذربيجان على كنباخ لكن
ما اصل وتاريخ هذا الصراع الذي بدا قبل
نحو قرن وراح ضحيته الالاف
عوامل تاريخيه وارقيه ودينيه وسياسيه
ساهمت جميعها في رسم طبيعه الصراع في
اقليم كنباخ الذي يقع في قلب الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه ويعترف القانون الدولي به
جزءا منها ويسكنه نحو 150 الفا غالبيتهم
من الارمن
الاول بين ارمينيا واذربيجان على الاقليم
كان عام
1918 حين اندلعت حرب بين الطرفين على
مناطق حدوديه قتل خلالها عشرات الاف
المدنيين وسيطرت فيها ارمينيا على اجزاء
شاسعه من غرب اذربيجان
وفي عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي انتجت تقسيمات
جغرافيه واثنيه لم تتلائم مع الخصوصيات
الديموغرافيه ومل الصراع اليقود بين
البلدين اللذين كانا جزءا من الاتحاد خلف
السطوه الشموليه السوفيتيه
وعقبا سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي مطلع
التسعينيات القرن الماضي غزت ارمينيا
كاراباخ وقامت فيها حكما ذاتيا للارمن في
خطوه لم يعترف بها المجتمع الدولي قتل
حينها 30 الف شخص ونزح اكثر من مليون ما
رجح الكفه الديموغرافيه في الاقليم لصالح
الارمله
وقبل ثلاث سنوات اي عام 2020 اندلقت حرب
واسعه استمرت لنحو سته اسابيع تمكنت
اذربيجان خلالها من استعاده قسم كبير من
اراضي كراباخ وانتهت الحرب باتفاق يتضمن
انتشار قوات روسيه على الارض للفصل بين
الطرفين كما تعهدت ارمينيا بالتخلي عن
المزيد من اراضي الاقليم والان التوتر
الجديد عاد بعد تحذيرات مراقبين من عدم
استكمال الاتفاق الذي انهى حرب 2020 وسط
مخاوفا اندلاع حرب جديده النزاع على كنباخ
الذي هو بالاساس سيرون عرقي قائم على
نزاعات قوميه اصبح مع مرور الوقت صراعا
اقليميا ودوليا ومجال تنافس يتعلق
بالمصالح بين دول عده